this is my
happy place
and it has been for a long long time
it's the ferry that goes from my parents
house near manly beach
to downtown sydney
there's nothing magical about the boat
itself tourists and locals ride this
thing every day
but really that's what makes this ferry
so special
no commuter ride on the planet offers up
more amazing city views
it's routine made spectacular
now you won't know it from my accent but
i spent a lot of time here as a kid
my aussie grandfather helped build the
sydney harbor bridge
and my aussie mum helped build the opera
house
i know i know the goatee it was a phase
cut me some slack
the point is i grew up eating things
like this
and worshipping these folks
my hope is that the aussie cred will buy
me some forgiveness
for what comes next
this country which punches far above its
weight in so many areas
has underachieved terribly when it comes
to technology
for years talented aussie coders have
escaped to silicon valley to make their
livings
and recent australian government
policies have underfunded science and
tech
as my pap would say
aussie tech is crook
there are signs though that australia
has turned on and started to retain some
of its homegrown tech
talent this then
is an odyssey to find the country's
rising stars
my journey goes from the beaches of
sydney to the artsy cosmopolitan streets
of melbourne
along the way i get lost in a cave with
only glowworms to guide me
go fishing with an internet playboy and
make friends with some dinosaurs
all on this episode of hello world
[Applause]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello world
check any survey of the best places to
live and you'll find
sydney near the top
it's a sprawling gorgeous city of about
four million
good-spirited people who love to be
outdoors
to party and to enjoy life
but there's a strong case to be made
that sydney ciders may be too content
at least when it comes to the city's
tech scene
while big companies like google and
microsoft have offices here
sydney can only point to a couple of
smash startups that have made it big
overseas that famous aussie pluck
has gone missing
there is however a tech revolution
building
and it's being led by young ambitious
scientists
they've left their fancy university labs
and migrated to sydney's tech
underground
and no one proves this point more than
the free radical i'll meet first
okay this spot doesn't exactly ooze
tech it's an artist warehouse in a
sydney suburb
but move deeper through the creative
commune and you'll find a makeshift
science lab
and this guy one of its founders a
transhumanist
polyamorous biohacker
you all know the type welcome to
biofoundry
australia's first open access molecular
biology lab
[Music]
sinister as it can sometimes sound bio
hacking has turned into an exciting new
field
it's do-it-yourself meddling with dna on
the cheap
to tweak nature and this is australia's
first biohacker lab
open to anyone willing to pay a
membership fee
let's get into it
[Music]
and the name of this biohacking pioneer
meow meow do you prefer to be mr meow mr
miami
hit up generous friends for a lot of the
scientific gear
and he hopes the lab will inspire people
of all stripes to give biotech a try
it's about pulling people in with
hands-on experiments
like extracting dna from the strawberry
if you stir or where the alcohol touches
the strawberries you'll be able to pull
out some stringy stuff and that's the
dna so that's the instructions to make a
strawberry
this is the first step in a biohack lab
pretty much anything we're doing with
molecular biology we're going to need to
get that dna out
the flavor genes the pigment genes we
can take these genes out and put them in
other things
so you might want to make an apple that
tastes like a strawberry you might be
able to
take the pigment jeans out and make a
new type of paint so you kind of take
the most interesting
properties of some organism extract it
out and then maybe
chuck it into something else and give it
some new superpowers that's it
yeah make everything glow a molecular
biologist by training
meow has put the lab to work on real
projects
ranging from anti-mold paint and
take-home std
tests to phosphorescent alcohol
cool damn straight it is
meow insisted that my next tutorial take
place in nature
we set out for the nunes state forest
located in the famed blue mountains
about five hours west of sydney
it's there that we hope to find the tiny
creature
at the heart of meows make everything
feel like a rave dreams
so we're about to go to the glowworm
tunnel it used to be a
railway tunnel they used in mining and
now it's been decommissioned
and the glowworms have come back and
reinhabited the the tunnel
i've waited this long and now i have to
ask you how did you get the name meow
meow
i wanted to change my name since i was
like 15. my friends and i just sat down
and we just wrote down a huge list of
names
and then we picked the one that sounded
the best
what's your full name now meow ludo
disco gamma meow meow
with the formalities out of the way the
time had come to meet one of australia's
lesser-known
biological attractions
glowworms are nocturnal they are
generally
less sensitive to red wavelengths of
light than they are white or blue light
i guess to see him best we've got to
turn this off
[Applause]
meow talks a lot about a lot of things
sometimes he's hyping a mango that's
been altered to do your laundry
and other times he's promoting
hallucinogenated orgies
to each his own but without question
meow's biohacking enthusiasm has worked
with labs modeled on this spot popping
up all around the country
prepare yourself australia for the
phosphorescent revolution
has begun
[Music]
putting all things phosphorescent behind
me it was time to leave sydney
and head south to the bustling city of
melbourne
melbourne lacks the surf culture of
sydney but has plenty going on
in a sport mad country melbourne is
considered the athletic capital
thanks to its massive venues for cricket
rugby and tennis
it's also something of a cultural
capital the elegant city gives off a
european charm
with its huge greek and italian
communities
a tram system and it takes great pride
in its laneways
which are alleys packed full of street
graffiti
and world-class restaurants one after
the other
if you're looking to eat your way
through australia this is a good place
to start the artsy up-and-comer vibe to
melbourne has had an impact on its tech
scene
people here have needed to think a bit
different to get attention
and it's paid off there's an argument to
be made that melbourne may be
australia's most promising tech hub
at least in terms of raw creativity
[Music]
the undisputed king of melbourne's tech
scene bears this thesis
out he's ruslan kogan the founder and
ceo of
kogan.com an online retailer that has
changed the way
australians shop we do about three times
more revenue per employee than amazon
he's a rich flamboyant controversial
workaholic
who finds an escape now and again at the
melbourne pier
all right let's go catch some snapper
okay
you must have been around like eight
years old when you moved here from
from belarus or six years old communism
is falling apart
my parents decided to leave which i'm so
thankful for
and came here with ninety dollars in
their pockets
[Music]
kogan grew up in melbourne's housing
projects and showed an entrepreneur's
spirit
right from the start as a kid
he ran a golf ball cleaning business a
car wash
and then a tech consulting operation
by the time he was 23 kogan had become
consumed with another quest
man's eternal hunt for an affordable
flat screen tv
i thought you know i can't afford it
from the shops but let me email some
factories
and i thought i'd tell them that i want
to order a hundred thousand tvs and
they'll get back to me
and then i'll ask for a sample and that
sample was going to be
my tv but when they started replying
with all of their quotes
i saw very quickly that there's a
brilliant market opportunity here
the big idea kogan hit on was to go
direct to chinese manufacturers to buy
tvs
for a fraction of the going price to get
the first batch of tvs
kogan maxed out a few credit cards and
had to borrow money from his friends
you're on this luck to just get a cheap
tv and it turns into a business idea
[Music]
australians had been slow to hop online
and local retailers had largely ignored
the web
kogen dragged the entire country online
and helped ignite
an internet retail boom today
kogan sells about 250 million dollars of
products per year
and rustling wants to expand the brand
overseas
and make kogan a household name should
we check if we still have bay
let's have a look not a single bite
what do you think should we keep trying
or should we drink beer
thanks babes
people keep telling me they feel like
australia was a little bit late took the
tech business but now it's
turning this corner you know i can't
tell if i'm getting spun or or if there
really is kind of a corner
being turned look we went through a time
in australia where our business leaders
and politicians
were talking about how bad online retail
is because it's gonna
it's gonna cost a lot of jobs in the
retail industry
luckily we're at a point now where
they're starting to realize that
innovation is the future there's only a
certain amount of stuff you can dig out
of the ground
our brain power and our ideas are an
unlimited resource
and if you can harness that one then
you're going to be a very rich nation
[Music]
if you're a hip city on the move what
you need
is a giant ferris wheel
the melbourne star opened in 2008
and is said to be the southern
hemisphere's only giant observation
wheel
whatever that means as far as big
technology and big science goes
melbourne can lay claim to some stunning
achievements
scientists here did pioneering work on
in vitro fertilization
heart valve replacement and cochlear
implants
and the big science journey into our
bodies continues on at a place
known as the australian synchrotron
the synchrotron cost 150 million dollars
to build
and opened in 2007 in this melbourne
suburb
the building basically functions like a
giant x-ray machine
slash microscope it propels electrons at
incredible speeds
and then manipulates them with magnetic
fields to produce a brilliant form of
light known
as synchrotron light this light can end
up being a million times brighter than
the sun
and can be tweaked by the building to
peer into a wide variety of objects
so far the synchrotron has been used to
examine plants and animals in fine
detail
and to peer through the layers of
objects like old paintings
soon it may be used to treat diseases
too
good andrew ashley how you doing nice to
meet you nice to meet you andrew peel is
a physicist
and the director of the synchrotron he
agreed to give me what's known as the
greg norman tour of the place
that's a sweet ride come aboard thank
you
some of these beam lines that we're
driving past there are researchers using
these
to do things like trying to cure cancer
different forms of disease
a lot of it's a bit like imagining a
lock and a key if you can understand
which locks fit which keys
you can turn diseases on and off you can
stop cancer in its tracks
recent anti-science australian
governments have threatened to slash
funding for labs like this as a result
many top scientists have left the
country but
in 2015 the synchrotron lucked out
and received 500 million dollars in
funding
over the next 10 years the hope is that
this facility can make money on its own
by doing commercial work yay science
[Music]
to get a closer look at this machine
hello daniel
hello how are you i spoke with daniel
hauserman a scientist here
who's looking at how the synchrotron can
diagnose
and treat cancer we use x-ray beam that
are billion times brighter than you
would
in the hospital so in the hospital it's
safe you put
your chest in a second you get a chest
x-ray
if you do a second without beam here
you burn you're done you smoke there's a
hole in your chest okay
because of its unique construction the
australian synchrotron
can make large beams 50 centimeters wide
or about the width of a human body this
means that the machine could be ideal
for turbocharged radiotherapy of tumors
we found that you can deliver doses
which are a thousand times higher
but more targeted more targeted and less
damage to the healthy tissue
okay so you could say that thousand grey
would kill a human being if it was
delivered
in a single shot broad area when you
make it in microbeams
it doesn't it actually destroy
tumors much better and spares healthy
tissue
it's not ready for human trials yet but
daniel thinks people may soon be able to
make an appointment
and have this building go to work on
your innards
it will be several years before we can
apply it to
actually a patient therefore the caveat
if anyone watches your show
and then call us and say i want to bring
you
my granddad because they can't treat
this cancer unfortunately
sorry we can't do it right now but maybe
one day but maybe in three or five years
yeah
these optimistic notes reflect just how
hard australian scientists must work
these days
to justify their jobs and provide the
government
with the hints that these types of
facilities may one day pay for
[Music]
themselves
but you know what's more fun than
anti-science bureaucrats
that would be dinosaurs
welcome to jurassic warehouse
is stegosaur stegosaur um is for a
jurassic world exhibition
this is our t-rex she tends to steal the
show and dominate the workshop
i keep thinking one of these things is
gonna eat me
sunny tildes hails from melbourne and
co-founded creature technology
since its birth in 2006 the company is
specialized in making giant
robotic animals and has ended up as one
of the biggest animatronics companies
around
[Music]
the creature team is made up of movie
special effects artists
who needed work during down periods
and their first project was a live show
called walking with dinosaurs
that ended up as the highest grossing
touring event in the world
in 2010. they've been in high demand
ever since
making rideable dragons a full-size king
kong
and cuddlier creations like these giant
stuffed animals for the sochi olympics
vladimir putin still likes to cuddle the
bunny rabbit on the right
we didn't know where this was going to
go we thought we'd all go back to film
and tv
but it grew out of this one show and we
realized that
there was something in this to bring
that sort of film level animatronics to
a live audience
this is the idominus rex
at the moment we're skinning the
creature and the girls are putting in
some scales each one of these creatures
takes about a year to create
every detail of the anatomy is built
from scratch
including the eyeballs the hydraulic
skeleton
and the lifelike fabric skin so it's
very similar to a real creature it's got
bones it's got muscles that's got skin
it's how they work together is uh that's
the trick really
to make the creatures seem more lifelike
the company's coders program
nuanced movement routines
but i'm not here to watch a computer
play with dinosaurs
i'm here to take a dino out for a spin
[Music]
so this is a voodoo rig so i'm actually
controlling the neck of this
parasaurolophus now
so this is all homegrown yeah i mean we
built these
um for our first live show 10 years ago
and this is our
rusty workshop model we'll never go yes
okay
he's designed to be intuitive and smooth
and so you can take him through his
whole range and he will go where you
want to
take him
[Music]
you have your own little pet dinosaur
yeah it's a lot of fun
there were a couple of new creations
coming to life in the creature workshop
that we weren't allowed to show you
secrecy remains paramount
in the vicious world of animatronics
it's safe to say though that the next
time a dinosaur
giant plush bear or say an alien
greets you at an amusement park then it
came from this place
on the other side of the world
australia has done well for itself in
recent years
its minds have churned out natural
resources that china has welcomed with
open wallets
there's the whole ugg boot thing and the
local soap operas have kept the rest of
the world
well stocked with attractive
entertainers
[Music]
as for tech it remains a mixed story
meow meow for example has decided to
form a startup in san francisco
because it proved easier to raise money
there
that said australia is still teams with
well-educated
and motivated engineers coders and
scientists
there are plenty of success stories now
for these youngsters to follow
there's also an undeniable urge for
australians to make a go of it at home
and prove what they're capable of
and if you fail the worst thing that can
happen is that you end up here
looking for another dash of courage in a
beer
coming up next on hello world i head to
england
to learn about the start of the
computing revolution
greetings to everyone watching hello
world and to get all gussied up
with the world's most advanced hair
dryer